the next spider-man's getting a
performance mode halo infinite is doing
something different with its structure
and there's some big news
for shin megami tensei fans i'm current
davina this is safe state game spots
big old news show for monday july 20th
first up spider-man miles morales is
gonna have a performance mode
now this isn't really new as a lot of
ps4 games have this
but what's interesting is that the
performance mode is gonna run at 4k
60 frames per second which leaves us to
ask
what's quality mode gonna be is it gonna
be 8k
at 120 frames per second is it gonna
have like
extra ray tracing and visual effects we
don't know yet
now given that spider-man ps4 is already
extremely impressive and beautiful
i'm very eager to see just how much
better spider-man miles morales
will look when it launches exclusively
on the ps5 this holiday next up
the xbox series x stream is just days
away
where we're supposed to see quite a bit
of halo infinite but ahead of schedule
we got a little news about the next halo
from xbox daddy x himself
phil spencer he said in an interview
with polygon
that the structure of the game will be
different
similar in ways to the master chief
collection he said quote there's been a
ton of learning in the studio and what
does it mean to actually have a
collection
the kind of totality of the halo lore
and stories and experience
inside one halo world one halo ui
and platform it's similar to our xbox
message and i think you'll see that in
terms of the way infinite is talked
about even the structure of the game
is itself which is definitely vague does
that mean it'll be broken up into
self-contained stories does that mean
it'll be released in parts over time
will they focus on individual characters
and paths
i don't know hopefully we'll get answers
this thursday at 9 am pt during the xbox
series x
stream which you can watch here on
gamespot's very own youtube channel
the long-awaited shin megami tensei 5 is
coming out in 2021
for the nintendo switch we don't have a
specific release date
but in a cool bit of news it's coming
out worldwide simultaneously which is
sweet
because like spoilers and stuff
alongside its announcement was a trailer
which premiered in today's nintendo
direct mini
also shin megami tensei 3 is getting an
hd
facelift and it's coming to both the ps4
and nintendo switch
in spring of 2021.
okay that's it for today's headlines
however we still have one more order of
business
and that is the plug the gamespot merch
story the place in which
you can buy this poster and also this
skateboard and t-shirts and a hoodie and
a face mask
and all the proceeds till the end of
august will be going to both black lives
matter and
kovid 19 relief a link to it will be
in the description below okay that's it
for today of course you can find out
about everything i just talked about
and a whole lot more by going to
gamespot.com i'm kurt devina
thanks for coming by what was that
oh my god be well drink water
you're good okay see ya
you